world is in our hands we gotta do
something with it
whatever it takes
whatever it takes
whatever it takes
[Music]
whatever it takes
[Music]
what's up everybody its Warren and
Marvel hit us with another big surprise
today dropping another Avengers endgame
TV spot trailer this time with a little
bit of new footage the new footage of
course focusing on Captain America who
seems to be getting most of the
spotlight with these trailers and TV
spots possibly a little bit of
foreshadowing in these trailers we also
get an extended look at banner in one
scene and he does not look like he's
doing okay this one starts off with the
new footage of Captain America saying
the world is in our hands we got to do
something with it one of the things to
note here is where he's at he's in the
support group for people who have lost
other people during the snap this is
something that we first saw in the
Avengers in game Super Bowl TV spot but
it sounds like he might actually be
talking to the rest of the Avengers
because he says the world is in our
hands we got to do something with it the
only people that really have any type of
power to do anything are the Avengers
and since the snap the world is probably
looking at the remaining Avengers
wondering if there's anything they're
going to do to try and undo what
happened
because they're the Avengers they're
Earth's Mightiest Heroes they've been
defending the planet since the Battle of
New York and people know who they are
now and even though the sokovia accords
happened the earth is still going to
look to them to save the day simply
because they're the only people that can
and after the snap there's going to be a
lot of chaos and confusion and it's
probably going to be Steve Rogers who
has to tell them what happened and when
he tells the world they're going to look
back at him and wonder what him and the
rest of the Avengers are going to do to
undo the snap and bring everybody back
because this is going right back to what
Tony said in the very first Avengers
movie if we can't protect the world you
can be sure that we'll avenge it and
that's exactly what they're going to be
doing in Avengers in game this film is
wrapping up the first 10 years of the
MCU and the Avengers are going to be
doing what they do
avenging so that's what Captain America
is referring to when he says the world
is in our hands we got to do something
with it and then we have this slightly
extended scene with Bruce Banner he
definitely looks very worried in this
scene he's definitely at the Avengers
compound it's widely believed right now
that Thanos and some of his army will
attack the Avengers compound so this
could be right when that's about to
happen we also know that Professor Hulk
is going to be
in Avengers in game so this could have
something to do with that Bruce Banner
trying to get the Hulk to come out but
still remaining in control and that's
basically this new TV spot this is
something very similar to what Marvel
did with Avengers infinity war right
before the movie came out they released
a ton of new TV spots all of which only
had a tiny bit of new footage so that's
something we can probably expect from
now until the movie comes out random new
TV spot trailers maybe with a little bit
of footage but just trying to get us
hype for Avengers in game so let me know
what you think about this new TV spot in
the comments down below and a reminder
about my giveaway I'm giving away five
imax tickets if you'd like to enter for
your chance to win all you have to do is
be a subscriber like this video and
comment down below with your thoughts
and your favorite superhero or villain
as always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof
[Music]